number 10 guts
that man's invincible he ran his sword
through that man as though you were
nothing
berserk is not your usual anime and guts
is anything but your usual anime
protagonist as an anime that dealt with
some very adult themes berserk was never
the one to shy away from death in
questions of morality and justice and
this struggle between duty and mercy
forms the basis of this classic anime
guts may be an extremely powerful man
but in the end he's just that a man he
desires to protect and avenge the people
he cares about and if his loved ones are
threatened he will take lives without
hesitation when his lover caska is
threatened by an army guts
single-handedly butchers the entire army
down to the last soldier earning the
nickname hundred man slayer and this is
just one instance of his brutality
throughout the course of the anime and
manga gut slaughters around a thousand
people himself while this does not seem
much it must be reiterated that he is
just a man unlike other shows with super
powers and magic to help guts takes
every life with his own hands often in
grotesque ways
number 9 matara uchiha
do not misunderstand it this is not
power of your creation
moderate was one of the most feared and
respected antagonists of the naruto
series he was the legendary leader of
the uchiha clan with the intention of
beginning an era of peace unfortunately
he died before he could complete his
plans but was later revived to finish
them with his vision to create an
infinite dream world trapping everyone
inside it maduro was an amazingly
manipulative foe with godlike ninja
abilities
during the events of the fourth great
ninja war matara dispatched the entire
fourth division with ease using his
abilities to wipe them out in minutes
along with his kills near the end of
this war this brings up his total kill
count to a ghastly ten thousand number
eight light yagami
and i
i will become the god of this new world
as far as anti-heroes go there is yet to
be one on par with light yagami with a
superhuman intelligence and a willpower
that matches his intellect light yagami
is a force to be reckoned with
his mastery of the death note allows him
control over death and light uses this
weapon to the full extent and is aimed
to create a world free of evil
however in his efforts to rid the worlds
of crime light shows no hesitation in
killing innocents or those who dare
oppose him throughout the cat and mouse
chase of death note light kills no less
than 120 000 people by all accounts this
is greater than even some shinigamis and
light showed no signs of stopping
anytime soon even contemplating killing
his own family to preserve his farce as
one of the most chilling sociopaths ever
animated light yagami has more than
earned his place on this list
number 7. father
[Music]
i think it's time to talk about the main
antagonist of the full metal alchemist
brotherhood the father he is arrogant
and self-righteous and he only seeks
power and ownership of the world despite
his humanoid forms father is a
homunculus not bound by human trappings
of mortality or retribution in his own
words he considers humans to be so
inferior that they are like insects to
him to be crushed without remorse to
gain immortality and godlike powers
father tricks an entire kingdom into
becoming a transmutation circle
harnessing the souls of over a million
people to turn himself and an acolyte
into living philosopher's stones
number six alucard and let me assure you
gentlemen
our vampire has power beyond imagination
not to be confused with castlevania's
alucard who is brutal in his own way but
nothing like our trench coat wearing
maniac alucard has all the abilities of
a vampire immortality intangibility
shape-shifting superhuman strength and
blood manipulation but what sets him
apart is the utter ruthlessness with
which he utilizes them against his
enemies he is someone who savors each
kill by torturing them with his gun
before killing them with a single bullet
the full extent of alucard's kill count
can only be seen when he unleashes level
zero allowing him to summon the souls of
everyone he has consumed and based on
the number of souls it's clear that he's
killed millions
number five lelouch v britannia lelouch
tania command you now all of you
die
the intriguing protagonist of code geass
is number five on our list for a good
reason not only is lelouch extremely
intelligent but he is an unyielding
stoic which allows him to make even the
most difficult decisions without any
remorse as the leader of the rebellion
against a tyrannical regime led by his
father no less the black prince has made
some very questionable choices in trying
to remove his father from power lelouch
sacrifices civilians and the military
alike to gain the upper hand his actions
in tokyo and the course of the rebellion
led to many deaths even by conservative
estimates his skill count is more than
two thousand but if we're looking at the
deaths caused by the results of his
actions the number would be in the
millions which lends credence to
lelouch's other alias the demon emperor
number 4. aaron yeager
[Music]
this may come as a shock to the fans of
the anime series but aaron jaeger the
apparent protagonist of attack on titan
now has one of the highest death counts
in anime even though the ending chapters
of the manga have yet to be animated we
know for sure that the boy who sought
freedom will go to any lengths to have
that not only does aaron turn against
his friends and comrades from the survey
corps no trace of his earlier desire to
protect innocence remains in an effort
to give his friends a chance at life
aaron decides to initiate the rumbling
killing more than 80 percent of the
world's population in the stampede of
the titans not only is he responsible
for the death of billions but aaron's
actions as attack titan have also been
responsible for most of the deaths in
the show so far making him one of the
deadliest anime protagonists for sure
number 3 beerus give me one of them now
i want the pudding beerus was one of the
first introductions to the god of
destruction in the dragon ball franchise
and from the very beginning it was
apparent that this feline god was among
the most powerful beings in the universe
as a god of destruction beerus job is to
maintain balance and he does this by
destroying entire planets and alien
races while he is a fearsome god his
cat-like gestures and his variety of
facial expressions separate him from the
more malevolent antagonists in the
series beerus has been destroying
planets for millions of years and if
each of those planets is home to at
least 1 billion individuals his kill
count is well into the billions
number 2 boros
not many people can survive saitama's
punch but boros was one of the
exceptions like saytama he faced a
self-imposed existential crisis having
become so powerful that no battle
thrilled him as an alien of remarkable
strength and a thirst for competition he
and his alien invaders roamed the galaxy
in search of worthy opponents even after
his arrival on earth boros destroyed an
entire city just to reveal his
intentions but even this massacre was
nothing compared to the devastation he
left behind in the other galaxies
destroying planet after planet just to
satisfy his craving for a decent fight
suffice to say burst's gill count is
easily in the billions
number one zeno
it's okay everybody you're funny and i
like funny the dragon ball franchise is
known for introducing powerful beings
after powerful beings but no one has
ever been as strong as zeno as the omni
king zeno is the supreme ruler of the
entire multiverse and despite his chubby
looks and childish demeanor he is a
ruthless god with the power to end all
life everywhere the multiverse is
currently made up of 13 universes but
there were originally 18 and zeno
decided to destroy six of them simply
because he was bored and thought 18 was
too many any given universe probably has
way more than trillions of individuals
living within it which means that zeno
killed trillions upon trillions of life
forms over six times just so he could
have a number of universes he fancies
with this said we think that you will
agree with us when we say that zeno
definitely deserves top spot on our list
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and turn on the bell icon for more
amazing anime content and we'll see you
guys next time